Kayak gets my flight, hotel, and rental car right, so I can tune out travel advice that's just plain wrong. Bro, Skycoin, way better than points. Never fly during a Scorpio full moon. Just tell the manager you'll sue. Instant room upgrade. Stop taking bad travel advice. Start comparing hundreds of sites with kayak and get your trip right. Bad advice. You talking to me? Kayak, got that right.
Kayak 能准确帮我订到机票、酒店和租车，让我不用听信那些大错特错的旅游建议。兄弟，Skycoin 绝对比积分好。千万别在天蝎座满月时坐飞机。直接告诉经理你要起诉他，就能瞬间升级房间。别再听信糟糕的旅游建议了，开始用 Kayak 对比数百个网站，让你的行程万无一失。糟糕的建议。你在跟我说话吗？Kayak，这就对了。
From Columbine to Sandy Hook to Parkland to Yuvaldi, the list of schools and communities devastated by gun violence grows every year. Every time a school shooting is in the news, it's easy to wonder what, if anything, could have been done differently. Were there signs that were missed? At what point, if any, could or should someone have intervened? Psychologists who study school violence have been researching these questions. Today we're going to talk about what they've found. So how common is gun violence in schools? How do most schools deal with the threat of violence right now?
从科伦拜恩到桑迪胡克，再到帕克兰和尤瓦尔迪，被枪支暴力摧毁的学校和社区名单每年都在增加。每当校园枪击案登上新闻，人们很容易想知道，当时本来可以做点什么、或者如果做了会有什么不同。是不是错过了什么迹象？在哪个时间点，如果可能的话，有人本可以或者应该进行干预？研究校园暴力的心理学家一直在研究这些问题。今天我们要谈谈他们的发现。那么，校园枪击暴力到底有多普遍？目前大多数学校是如何应对暴力威胁的？
How can teachers, administrators, and law enforcement officials tell real threats of violence from false alarms or pranks? When a real threat is identified, what kind of interventions work? And how can schools avoid underreacting to genuine threats and overreacting to false ones? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Dewey Cornell. Dr. Cornell is a forensic clinical psychologist and the Virgil S. Ward Professor of Education
教师、行政人员和执法人员如何将真正的暴力威胁与虚假警报或恶作剧区分开来？当识别出真正的威胁时，什么样的干预措施才有效？学校又该如何避免对真正的威胁反应不足，以及对虚假威胁反应过度？欢迎收看《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客节目，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是杜威·康奈尔博士。康奈尔博士是一名法医临床心理学家，同时也是弗吉尼亚大学的维吉尔·S·沃德教育学教授。
at the University of Virginia, where he directs the Virginia Youth Violence Project. He is the principal author of the Comprehensive School Threat Assessment. guidelines, which is an evidence-based model of school threat assessment used in schools across the United States and Canada. He's currently directing a national study of school threat assessment with funding from the U.S. Department of Justice. Dr. Cornell has authored more than 300 publications in psychology and education, including studies of juvenile homicide, school safety, bullying, and threat assessment.
他在弗吉尼亚大学指导弗吉尼亚青少年暴力项目。他是《综合学校威胁评估指南》的主要作者，这是一套在美国和加拿大学校中广泛使用的基于证据的校园威胁评估模型。目前，他在美国司法部的资助下，正在主持一项关于校园威胁评估的国家级研究。康奈尔博士在心理学和教育学领域撰写了300多篇出版物，其中包括关于青少年谋杀、校园安全、欺凌和威胁评估的研究。
Dr. Cornell, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for inviting me. Before we start talking about threat assessment, which I want to do, let's put this discussion in some context. This episode won't air until January, but today we're talking right now in late December, the day after another school shooting, this one in Madison, Wisconsin. So the topic feels especially important right now. In this atmosphere, it's hard for students and their parents not to feel worried about sending their kids to school. every day. So I want to start with the question, how common is gun violence in U.S. schools and how worried should students and parents be about the threat of school shootings? That's a very
康奈尔博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。谢谢您的邀请。在我们开始讨论威胁评估之前——这也是我想谈的内容——让我们先把这场讨论放在一定的背景之下。这期节目要到一月才会播出，但我们今天录制的时间是在十二月下旬，也就是又一起校园枪击案发生后的第二天，这次的案发地点在威斯康星州麦迪逊市。所以，这个话题在当下显得格外重要。在这种氛围下，学生和家长很难不为每天送孩子去上学感到担忧。因此我想先问一个问题：在美国学校里，枪支暴力究竟有多普遍？学生和家长对于校园枪击的威胁到底该感到多大程度的担忧？这是一个非常
important question. And certainly when we've had another tragic shooting like we've just had this week, it's very hard not to feel that schools are not safe places, that gun violence seems to be pervasive and parents understandably are very worried about sending their children to school. But I want to offer a little bit of reassurance there. On the one hand, gun violence is a very serious problem in the United States, but it's actually less frequent in schools than it is outside of schools. And that statistically speaking, we have 130,000 schools, even though we've had a number of school shootings, the average school is very unlikely to ever have a homicide shooting. It calculates out about once every 6,000 years. So, although it seems counterintuitive, schools are
重要的问题。当然，当我们经历本周刚刚发生的那起悲惨枪击案时，我们很难不觉得学校不是安全的地方，枪支暴力似乎无处不在，家长们担心送孩子上学也是完全可以理解的。但我想给大家吃一颗定心丸。一方面，枪支暴力是美国一个非常严重的问题，但它在学校发生的频率实际上比学校外面要低。从统计学上讲，我们有13万所学校，尽管我们发生过不少校园枪击案，但平均每所学校几乎永远都不会遭遇枪击命案。据计算，大约每6000年才会轮到一次。因此，尽管这听起来有些反直觉，但在统计上，学校
statistically one of the safest places from gun violence in the United States. We have more gun violence in our stores and restaurants and parks and parking lots and in our homes by a large margin than we have in schools. So don't get me wrong. School shootings are a terrible tragedy. We have to do everything we can to to prevent them, but statistically, schools are much safer than it feels. Around the beginning of this school year after the shooting at Appalachie High School in Georgia, there was a surge in violent threats against schools nationwide. These were really disruptive, in some cases, closing schools for days. Disurges like this usually follow high-profile shootings, and when they do,
是美国遭受枪支暴力威胁最安全的地方之一。我们在商店、餐馆、公园、停车场以及自己家里遭遇的枪支暴力，要远远多于学校。所以请不要误解我的意思。校园枪击案是一场可怕的悲剧，我们必须竭尽所能去阻止它们，但从统计数据来看，学校要比我们的直感安全得多。今年开学初，在佐治亚州阿巴拉契州立高中发生枪击事件后，全国范围内针对学校的暴力威胁激增。这些威胁造成了极大的干扰，在某些情况下甚至导致学校停课数天。像这样的激增通常发生在备受关注的枪击事件之后，而每当这种情况发生时，
how can schools and law enforcement tell serious threats from pranks or copycats? Yes, after a school shooting, we do see a surge in student threats, but we also see a surge in sensitivity to threats. So statements and behaviors that might otherwise have been ignored or handled informally become more concerning in the wake of a school shooting to school authorities and to law enforcement So they also react strongly. So we have both students being stimulated by school shootings to say and do threatening things, and we have authorities who are on edge and worried and reacting strongly to student behavior.
学校和执法部门该如何区分严肃的威胁与恶作剧或模仿行为？是的，在校园枪击案发生后，我们确实会看到学生发出的威胁激增，但我们也会看到人们对威胁的敏感度激增。因此，在校园枪击案发生后，学校当局和执法部门对那些原本可能会被忽视或非正式处理的言论和行为会变得更加关注，他们也会做出强烈的反应。所以我们看到的是双向的：一方面是校园枪击刺激了学生说出和做出具有威胁性的行为，另一方面是当局处于高度戒备、焦虑不安的状态，对学生的行为做出了强烈反应。
As I said a minute ago, school statistically will almost never have an actual shooting or an actual homicide, not in thousands of years, but every school has threats. schools frequently deal with students who say or do things that are threatening or concerning in some way. So it's a pervasive problem. At the same time, the worst possible outcome is very unlikely. And so that creates a real dilemma for schools. What do we do with students who make threatening statements? And that leads us to the comprehensive school threat assessment guidelines that you were involved in creating. Can you tell us about those guidelines and how does this model of threat assessment work? Sure. So threat assessment is a form of violence prevention that was originally developed by the Secret Service to protect public figures.
正如我刚才所说，从统计学上讲，学校几乎永远不会发生真正的枪击案或谋杀案，数千年都不会发生，但每一所学校都会面临威胁。学校经常要处理那些说出或做出某种具有威胁性或令人担忧的行为的学生。因此，这是一个普遍存在的问题。与此同时，最坏的结果发生的可能性极低。这就给学校带来了真正的两难境地：我们该如何处理那些发出威胁性言论的学生？这就引出了您参与制定的《综合学校威胁评估指南》。能给我们介绍一下这些指南，以及这种威胁评估模型是如何运作的吗？当然可以。威胁评估是一种暴力预防形式，最初是由特勤局为保护公众人物而开发的。
But within a few years, folks began to realize that the general principles of behavioral threat assessment and management, that's the formal term for it, could be used to prevent workplace violence, domestic violence, and as we started to see, shootings in schools increase in the 90s, the FBI and Secret Service said, hey, why don't we try this in schools to prevent school shootings? And that's when I went from a meeting with the FBI back to Charlottesville to the University of Virginia. And I talked with my students and colleagues. And I said, hey, let's try to develop something. And so we work with a group of local educators, folks in the trenches, in the classroom, in the hallways, to say, how do we deal with students who make threatening statements in a way that's going to be reasonable and fair, safe, and avoid the two errors of threat assessment. The two errors are overreaction to threats that are not serious and
但在几年之内，人们开始意识到行为威胁评估与管理（这是它的正式名称）的一般原则，可以用来预防工作场所暴力、家庭暴力，并且正如我们在90年代看到校园枪击案不断增加时那样，FBI和特勤局表示，嘿，为什么我们不尝试在学校里用它来预防校园枪击呢？就在那时，我从与FBI的一次会议回到夏洛茨维尔，回到了弗吉尼亚大学。我和学生以及同事们进行了交流。我说，嘿，让我们试着开发点东西。于是，我们与当地的一群教育工作者合作——也就是那些身处一线、在教室和走廊里工作的人——探讨如何在合理、公平、安全的前提下处理学生发出威胁性言论的问题，同时避免威胁评估中的两种错误。这两种错误是：对并不严重的威胁反应过度，以及
underreaction to the rare threats that are truly serious where someone poses a serious threat. And so we developed the set of guidelines. We worked with local schools. We tested them. We refined them. We developed a manual, and then we did all the stuff that academics do. That is, we conducted a series of studies and went out and got grants and developed the training program and so forth. So in the real world, what does this feel like? What does it look like? So if I'm a school administrator and I'm following the threat assessment guidelines, how do I make the judgment that this is a serious threat or this is not a serious threat? Okay. So threat assessment is all about collecting information from multiple sources, using a multidisciplinary team, so it's not on the shoulders of one person
对真正严重、某人构成了真正严重威胁的罕见情况反应不足。于是我们制定了一套指南。我们与当地学校合作，对它们进行了测试、改进，编写了一本手册，然后做了所有学者都会做的事情。也就是说，我们开展了一系列研究，申请了资助，开发了培训计划，诸如此类。那么在现实世界中，这感觉如何？它看起来是什么样的？所以，如果我是一名学校管理员，并且正在遵循威胁评估指南，我该如何判断这是一个严重的威胁，还是一个不严重的威胁？好的。威胁评估的核心在于从多个来源收集信息，并利用一个多学科团队，因此这个沉重的决定
to make this weighty decision, but with a multidisciplinary team with school administration, school support staff, that is counselor, psychologist, social workers, and if they have a school resource officer, also the law enforcement officer, but all of them together will gather information. So we have an interview protocol for this student who's been identified as a student of concern, We have an interview that we use for witnesses and reporters of concern. We look at the student's background and history. And depending on how complex and serious the threat is, we may be able to resolve it quickly and easily. A student was just joking or they were expressing themselves in an exaggerated way.
不会压在某一个人的肩上。这个多学科团队包括学校行政人员、学校支持人员（即辅导员、心理学家、社工），如果他们配备了学校驻校警察，还包括执法人员。所有人共同收集信息。因此，我们针对被认定为受关注学生的个体制定了一套访谈规程；我们针对目击者和报告担忧的人制定了访谈方案；我们会查看学生的背景和历史。根据威胁的复杂性和严重程度，我们或许能够迅速而轻松地解决问题。也许某个学生只是在开玩笑，或者他们只是用夸张的方式表达自己。
But if there's reason to be more concerned, things don't quite add up or we're not really confident the young person is being straight with us. Then we do a more intensive assessment with more extensive interviewing and gathering of data. We might involve law enforcement in some cases. We might conduct searches for weapons. We might do a home visit. So our guidelines really have a kind of calibrated step-by-step approach. We have five steps. And some threats are resolved at step one, some at step two, some at step three, and so forth.
但如果有理由感到更多担忧，事情有些说不通，或者我们对这个年轻人是否对我们坦诚没有太大信心。那么，我们会进行更深入的评估，包括更广泛的访谈和数据收集。在某些情况下，我们可能会让执法部门介入。我们可能会搜查武器，也可能会进行家访。因此，我们的指南实际上采用了一种经过校准的逐步推进的方法。我们有五个步骤。有些威胁在第一步就解决了，有些在第二步，有些在第三步，以此类推。
So it's a calibrated process based on the complexity and seriousness of the case. What does the research say about how effective threat assessment is? Do you have evidence that it's prevented school shootings and are there other outcomes that you're looking for in your research? Yeah. So there's a lot of outcomes that we're looking for. We've done a half a dozen controlled studies involving hundreds of schools. We've done some implementation studies with thousands of schools. And so we know that most cases can be resolved without removing. moving the student from school without expelling them, without arresting them, and we can provide them services because we identify problems that they're having pure conflicts and bullying.
所以这是一个根据案件的复杂性和严重程度进行校准的过程。研究显示威胁评估到底有多有效？你们是否有证据表明它预防了校园枪击，在研究中你们还关注了哪些其他结果？是的。我们关注了很多结果。我们已经开展了数十项涉及数百所学校的对照研究，也对数千所学校进行了实施研究。因此我们知道，大多数案件都可以在不将学生移出学校、不让他们退学、不逮捕他们的前提下得到解决，我们可以为他们提供服务，因为我们识别出了他们遇到的问题——比如同伴冲突和欺凌。
And we've got lots of data to show that that can be done. It can be done effectively and safely. Very few threats result in some kind of violent action. We've had some fights, but no shooting, thankfully, no homicides. But the question, of course, people want to ask is, well, have you prevented a school shooting? Well, certainly, we have cases. We're students seem to have been very serious about committing a homicide, and they've been resolved, and we've had no homicides. But let me just say scientifically, you need a randomized controlled trial, and school shootings are so rare, as I mentioned, fatal shootings are about once every 6,000 years for the average school. If you think about that from a statistical point of view,
我们有大量数据表明这是做得到的，而且可以做得既有效又安全。极少有威胁最终演变成某种暴力行为。我们处理过一些打架斗殴，但值得庆幸的是没有枪击，也没有谋杀。但人们当然想问的问题是：“好吧，你们阻止了校园枪击吗？”嗯，当然，我们遇到过一些案例，学生看起来非常认真地想要实施谋杀，但这些案件得到了解决，而且我们没有发生谋杀案。不过，我要从科学的角度说，你需要进行随机对照试验，但校园枪击事件是如此罕见，正如我所提到的，对于普通学校来说，致命枪击案大约每6000年发生一次。如果你从统计学的角度来考虑这一点，
you need thousands of schools that you're going to follow over multiple years to be able to demonstrate that you have reduced the rate of school shootings because school shootings are quite statistically rare. And so I can't claim that we've done a randomized controlled trial of school shootings, but we do have controlled studies to show that we can reduce a lot of conflicts and problems in schools. We can show that students feel safer in those schools, teachers feel safer in those schools. And about three-fourths of the students get referred for support services. So we identify a lot of problems like bullying or peer conflicts or maybe mental health needs. We have a lot of kids with special education with disabilities that we need to make referrals to their special ed team to maybe enhance their program or their plan.
你需要对数千所学校进行多年的追踪，才能证明你降低了校园枪击率，因为校园枪击在统计学上相当罕见。因此，我不能宣称我们做过关于校园枪击的随机对照试验，但我们确实有对照研究表明，我们可以减少学校中的许多冲突和问题。我们可以证明，在这些学校里，学生感到更安全，老师也感到更安全。大约四分之三的学生被转介接受支持服务。因此，我们识别出了许多问题，比如欺凌、同伴冲突或心理健康需求。我们有很多残疾的特殊教育儿童，我们需要将他们转介给他们的特教团队，以便可能改进他们的项目或计划。
What are the roles of the various people within the school regarding threat assessment? For example, teachers, administrators, other students, what do they have to do to be effective in stopping school shootings before they happen? Yeah. Well, safety is everyone's responsibility. Parents, teachers, students, support staff. Everyone needs to be observant. and if they have concern, they need to report their concern. That's all they need to do. They don't need to do a threat assessment themselves. They don't need to make a determination that someone is or is not dangerous.
在威胁评估中，学校内各类人员扮演着什么角色？例如，教师、行政人员、其他学生，他们需要做些什么才能在校园枪击发生之前有效地阻止它们？嗯，安全是每个人的责任。家长、教师、学生、支持人员。每个人都需要保持观察，
If they are concerned about something, the schools should have multiple ways for them to report it. Of course, we'd like them to just come forward and talk to a trusted adult. That's the most effective way. But some schools will use an anonymous reporting system. That's fine. it doesn't give as much information often as we would like, but in any way that a concern can be reported, then the team, it's their responsibility to gather additional information and make that kind of determination about the seriousness of the threat.
如果有担忧，他们就需要报告他们的担忧。这就是他们需要做的全部。他们不需要自己去进行威胁评估，也不需要判断某人是否危险。如果他们对某事感到担忧，学校应该为他们提供多种报告途径。当然，我们希望他们能直接站出来，跟信任的成年人谈谈。那是最高效的方式。但有些学校会使用匿名举报系统。那也行，虽然它往往无法提供我们想要的那样多的信息，但无论通过什么方式报告担忧，团队都有责任收集更多信息，并对威胁的严重程度做出这种判断。
But we need everyone in the school to understand that there's a process, that it's a fair, systematic process, that it gathers information, and it's not going to mean that every student is removed from school. That's kind of a problem we run to in threat assessment because, you know, parents and teachers and students are worried. And if a rumor gets out of hand and someone thinks that a student is dangerous, the first thing that people think is, well, let's get them out of the school. Let's remove them from the school. That turns out not to be an effective safety response and it's certainly not helpful to the student. So we want to, in most cases, provide services and support, resolve a conflict, resolve an underlying problem. and then move on from there.
但我们需要学校里的每个人都明白，这是一个流程，一个公平、系统化的流程，它会收集信息，并且这并不意味着每个学生都会被逐出学校。我们在威胁评估中经常遇到这样一种问题，因为家长、老师和学生都很焦虑，如果谣言失控，有人认为某个学生很危险，人们的第一反应就是：“好吧，把他弄出学校。把他从学校里赶出去。”事实证明，这不是一个有效的安全对策，对学生也绝对没有帮助。因此，在大多数情况下，我们希望提供服务和支持，化解冲突，解决潜在问题，
So if you're not going to remove a student, what are the alternatives? What's something that does work when you're seeing a student who is problematic in that way? Okay. So every threat is different. Sometimes a threat is just a joke and it can be resolved with an apology and clarification. Sometimes the threat is because somebody is headed with somebody and they're itching for a fight. And so if you work in middle school, you know, middle school kids will get into fistfire. And, you know, our school counselors and psychologists, they mediate conflicts between youngsters.
然后在此基础上继续前进。那么，如果不把学生逐出学校，还有什么替代方案？当你遇到一个在这方面有问题的学生时，什么方法真正管用？好吧。每个威胁都是不同的。有时威胁只是个玩笑，可以通过道歉和澄清来解决。有时威胁是因为某人跟别人合不来，手痒想打一架。如果你在初中工作过，你就会知道初中生会大打出手。我们的学校辅导员和心理学家会调解年轻人之间的冲突，
And we certainly want to support that. And it usually works. And what we found is that very few threat cases result in some kind of physical assault, about 5%. And those are almost all fights, as I said, very few injuries in the state of Florida. We looked at 23,000 cases. and we found, you know, almost all of them were resolved without any kind of assault or fight. We had 10,000 cases where we looked at what kind of injury occurred and less than half of a percent had a serious injury where someone maybe had to go to the ER for some kind of injury. So those are very, very low rates and most of the time we're trying to draw upon the school's support services.
我们当然希望支持这种做法。这通常很管用。我们发现，极少数威胁案件会导致某种身体攻击，比例大约为5%左右。正如我所说，这些几乎全都是打架斗殴，受伤的情况极少。在佛罗里达州，我们考察了23,000起案件，发现几乎所有案件都在没有发生任何攻击或斗殴的情况下得到了解决。我们研究了10,000起案件中发生了何种伤害，结果显示，不到0.5%的案件造成了严重伤害，即有人可能因某种伤情不得不去急诊室。因此，这些比率非常非常低，而且在大多数时候，我们都在试图利用学校的支持服务。
So a school might have multi-tiered systems of support. They certainly have special education services. They may have PBIS. They may have restorative practices. They may have anti-bullying programs. The whole range of support programs that we already have in schools can be selectively applied in most threat assessment cases. Now, I read a story in the newspaper just the other day about how students are using cell phones
所以学校可能会有多层支持系统。他们当然有特殊教育服务，可能有PBIS（积极行为支持系统），可能有恢复性实践，可能有反欺凌项目。我们在学校里已经拥有的整套支持项目，都可以在大多数威胁评估案例中有选择地应用。现在，我前几天在报纸上读到一则新闻，讲的是学生如何使用手机来煽动暴力并记录彼此的暴力冲突。然而，你刚才听起来好像这并不是什么大问题。我的意思是，这到底是不是个问题？学校里的手机本质上是否在煽动孩子们做出更多出格的行为？好吧，我并不是想暗示我们在学校里不存在学生行为问题，事实上我们的攻击性行为确实有所增加。而且我们有很多心理健康问题，学校里的人手根本不足以应付。所以听起来我好像不是在淡化这个问题，但我想说的是，这个问题其实并不在于
to spur violence and record each other having violent altercations. And yet you're making it sound like. like it's not really a problem. I mean, is it a problem or cell phones in school essentially spurring kids to act out more? Well, I'm not trying to imply that we don't have a problem with student behavior in schools, and we've had some increase in aggressive behavior. And we have a lot of mental health concerns that we're not fully staffed in our schools to be able to manage. So I don't want to sound like I am dismissing the problem, but I'm saying the problem is not so much.
校园枪击案——虽然这些案件非常可怕，但它们极为罕见。而在水面之下，有许多孩子正在经历冲突、问题和欺凌。对于这些事情，我们需要利用心理学家为学校开发的大量循证项目去妥善处理。没人去汉克斯店里买电子表格。他们去是为了吃一块美味可披萨。不过最近，店里一直很冷清。于是汉克斯决定重新推出一美元披萨切片。他请 Microsoft Excel 中的 Copilot 查看他的销售额和成本，帮他算算是否负担得起。Copilot 向汉克斯展示了资金的流向，以及哪些额外小费能让一美元披萨的方案行得通。
school shootings, which are terrible, but very rare. But under the radar screen, we've got a lot of kids having conflicts and problems and bullying. And those things we need to deal with with a lot of the evidence-based programs that the psychologists have developed for use in schools. No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks co-pilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs. Help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
现在，汉克斯店门口排起了长队。汉克斯做披萨，Copilot 处理电子表格。访问 M365 copilot.com slash work 了解更多信息。在过去的几年里，关于警察（通常被称为驻校警察）是否应该在学校工作，存在着很多争论。你的观点是什么？执法人员在校园威胁评估中应该扮演什么角色？是的。我们确实看到了一些案例，在这些案例中，执法人员似乎反应过度。在发生备受瞩目的枪击事件后，我们会看到诸如10岁儿童或12岁儿童被捕的案例。在许多这样的案件中，当我们深入调查事情的真相时，发现当事人的行为其实并没有那么严重，根本不至于招致逮捕或刑事化。当然，在某些情况下，逮捕是必要的。但这造成了一种看法，即也许我们需要让执法部门
Now, Hanks has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Copilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365 copilot.com slash work. In the past several years, has been a lot of debate about whether police officers, who are often called school resource officers, should be working in schools. What's your view? What role should law enforcement play in school threat assessment? Yeah. Well, we've seen some cases where it seems that law enforcement has overreacted. And after a high profile shooting, we'll see cases of, you know, a 10-year-old being arrested or 12-year-old being arrested. And in many of those cases, when we dig into the facts of what happened, it wasn't that severe an act. It didn't justify arrest or criminalization. Now, there are some cases where, arrest is necessary, of course. But this has created a perception that maybe we need to get law enforcement
离开学校。但我认为，问题真正出现的时候，往往是执法人员没有留在学校里作为团队的一部分共同工作。所以在威胁评估中，我们希望他们成为团队的一部分。我们希望他们接受培训，我们希望他们理解我们所使用的方法。我们发现执法部门对此非常接受。当我们的执法人员成为接受过培训的团队成员时，我们得到了非常好的结果。少于1%的学生被逮捕。当驻校警察不负责维持纪律，而是充当榜样、辅导员和学校的支持来源时，他们可以产生积极的影响。不过，我确实担心执法人员可能没有经过充分的培训、准备或筛选来在学校工作。因此，我们在改进这方面还有很多工作要做。但我当然认为，把他们赶出学校绝对是自找麻烦。许多学校发现，当警察被撤走后，谁来拉开打架的人？如果你在学校大厅里遇到了一场混战，难道你要叫历史老师挺身而出、直面危险去处理吗？当然，根据我们的调查，绝大多数学生也认为驻校警察的存在让他们在学校里感到更安全。不仅如此，跨越不同的种族群体，这都是成立的——黑人、西班牙裔、白人以及其他种族群体都是如此。
out of schools. But I think the problem really arises when law enforcement are not in the schools working as part of the team. So what we do in threat assessment is we want them to be part of the team. We want them to go through the training. We want them to understand the approach that we use. And we found that law enforcement is very receptive to this. And when we have law enforcement as trained members of the team, we get very good results. Fewer than 1% of the students are arrested. And law enforcement officers in schools can have a positive effect when they're not enforcing discipline, but being role models and counselors and sources of support in the school. Now, I am concerned that law enforcement officers might not be adequately trained or prepared
我们为此做过全州范围的调查。我知道有些情况下事情处理得不好，我们需要进行干预以让情况变得更好。但总体而言，我认为如果执法人员经过良好的培训、受到监督、拥有明确的职责，他们可以成为学校里的一股积极力量。是的，我也确实担心那些用手机拍摄打架画面并将其发到网上的学生。这产生了巨大的传染效应。
or selected to work in school. So we've got a lot of work to do to improve that. But I certainly think putting them out of schools is a recipe for trouble. Many schools have found that when the officers were removed, who's going to break up the fight? If you have a melee in the school in the lobby, are you asking the history teacher, the step-ins into harm's way and do something about it? And of course, students also, in our surveys, the vast majority of students feel that the presence of the school's resource officer makes them feel safer in the school. Now, this is across racial groups. This is true for black, Hispanic, white, other racial groups.
每个人都想插上一脚，参与做一些像这样耸人听闻的事情。因此，我们需要围绕社交媒体的危害以及适当的行为，对学生进行大量的教育。并且我们需要对学校中手机的使用进行一些限制。你刚才提到执法人员有时会反应过度。比如10岁或更小的儿童，他们并没有构成严重的威胁。我只是想知道，威胁评估对于不同的年龄或年级段是否有所不同？我的意思是，学校应该如何应对来自非常小的孩子（比如小学低年级学生）的威胁？
We've done statewide surveys of that. I know there are situations where things have gone poorly, where we need to have interventions to make things go better. But on the whole, I think law enforcement can be a positive force in schools. If they're well-trained, supervised, have a well-defined role. And, yes, I am concerned about the students with cell phones who are, are taking images of fights and putting them on the internet. And that has a great contagious effect.
是的。你总是必须考虑孩子的年龄和发展水平。如果他们有残疾或任何其他心理健康或教育状况，你也必须将这些考虑在内，
Everybody wants to get in on the act and be part of doing something as sensational as that. So we have to do a lot of education with our students around the hazards of social media, around appropriate behavior. And we need to have some restrictions on the use of cell phones in our schools. You mentioned a moment ago about sometimes overreacting by law enforcement. 10-year-olds or younger children who really are not seriously threatening. And I'm just wondering whether threat assessment works differently for different ages or grade levels. I mean, how should a school respond to a threat from a very young child like in elementary school?
才能理解他们的出处、他们的意图以及他们有能力做出什么行为。事实上，我们在小学进行的威胁评估比在中学还要多。那里的孩子更多，他们心智不成熟，而且由于年龄原因，他们说话做事往往会出于冲动。在大多数情况下，绝大多数（高达80%）此类案件都被判定为所谓的“短暂威胁”，并不严重。随着孩子们长到初中和高中，他们的冲动性会有所减少。
Yeah. Well, you always have to consider the child's age, their developmental level. If they have a disability or any other kind of mental health or educational condition, you have to consider that. to understand where they're coming from, what they meant, and what they're capable of doing. We actually have more threat assessments conducted in elementary school than we do in secondary school. There's more of those kids, and they're immature, and they will say and do things impulsively because of their age. And in most of the cases, the vast majority, 80% of those cases, which resolved is what we call a transient threat that's not serious. As kids get older into middle and secondary school, they're a little less impulsive.
他们发出的威胁会变少，但这些威胁背后包含的担忧会更多一些，因为他们更有能力伤害别人。因此，我们必须根据孩子的年龄调整威胁评估流程。当然，通过使用以学校为基础的团队，我们能够做到这一点，因为我们希望身处学校、熟悉学校、熟悉学生以及学校文化的人来做这些决定，而不是让一个使用统一标准的外部权威来做决定。我认为，八岁小孩说的话和十六岁少年说的话有很大区别。我们对他们行为的期望也
They make fewer threats, but those threats have a little bit more concern behind them because they're more capable of injuring someone. And so we have to adjust the threat assessment process to the age of the child. And of course, by using a school-based team, we're able to do that because we want the folks who are in the school, who are familiar with their school, their students, the culture of their school. We want them making these decisions rather than maybe an authority from outside who's using a uniform set of standards. And I think, you know, it's a big difference between an eight-year-old saying something and a 16-year-old saying something. And our expectations for their behavior are
不同。不幸的是，如果执法部门或任何外部权威机构强行套用一套不考虑学生年龄的严格统一标准，这就存在反应过度的潜在风险。那么，学校如何才能避免对严重威胁反应不足，以及对不严重的威胁反应过度呢？这就是为什么他们需要一个基于证据的威胁评估项目。这是一种系统化的方法，用以收集信息、与同事分享并做出合理的决定。威胁评估并不是完美的，它无法保证永远正确。但我们发现，我们可以大幅减少将学生赶出学校的情况，减少对孩子进行惩罚而非提供帮助的情况。这非常
different. And unfortunately, if law enforcement or, you know, outside authorities of any kind, are applying a strict uniform standard that doesn't consider the age of the student, there's a potential for overreaction there. Well, how can schools avoid underreacting to serious threats and overreacting to unsurious threats? Well, that's why they need an evidence-based threat assessment program. It's a systematic way to gather information, share it with colleagues, and make a reasonable decision. threat assessment isn't perfect. It's not guaranteed to always be correct. But what we found is that we can dramatically reduce removing kids from school, kids being punished rather than helped. And that's very
重要，因为正如我所说，几乎没有一所学校会真正发生枪击事件。但每一所学校都会遇到学生发出威胁的情况。因此，如果我们实行零容忍政策，就会引发巨大的问题。许多学校都在实行零容忍政策。他们会说：“不管出于什么情况，不管你多大年龄，只要你违反了规定，我们就得把你开除出学校。”而研究发现，把孩子开除出学校并不能改善他们的行为，也无法让学校变得更安全。相反，它增加了这个学生在未来行为不端并从学校辍学的可能性。因此，我们在使用“开除出学校”这一手段时必须非常谨慎。我会，我会把一个学生开除出学校，当且仅当他的确极度不安全，且拥有一个与普通教室或普通学校不同的、更有结构和支持性的环境才真正符合该儿童的最佳
important because, as I said, almost no school will ever have a shooting. But every school is having students make threats. And so there's a big problem there if we were to apply zero tolerance. And many schools use zero tolerance. They say, you've broken the rule, regardless of the circumstances, regardless of your age, whatever, we're going to remove you from school. And what research has found is that, you know, removing kids from school doesn't improve their behavior. It doesn't make the school safer. It increases the likelihood that the student is going to misbehave and drop out of school down the road. So we want to be very careful about using school removal. I would, I would remove a student from school when it's just really clearly not safe and it's in the child's best
利益。但我们发现，在绝大多数情况下，这是没有必要的。在这个大杂烩里，有没有哪个人比其他人更关键或更重要？是那些报告威胁的其他学生，还是老师、辅导员，甚至是家长？是的。当涉及到报告担忧时，我们希望每个人都知道如何做，并且愿意去看到“告密”与“寻求帮助”之间的区别。但我们在研究校园枪击案时发现——无论是已经发生的校园枪击案，还是被成功阻止的校园枪击案——通常都是某个学生掌握了关键信息，或者知道了某些内情。因此，我们非常
interest to have a different, more structured and supportive environment than the regular classroom or the regular school. But what we have found is that in a vast majority of cases, that's not necessary. Is there anybody in this whole mix who is more critical or pivotal than anybody else? Is it other students who report the threats or teachers or guidance counselors or even parents. Yeah. Well, when it comes to reporting concerns, we want everybody to know how and be willing and to see the difference between snitching and seeking help. But what we have found when we study school shootings, school shootings that have occurred and school shootings that have averted, that usually it's a student who has key information, who knows something. And so we very much
希望鼓励学生进行举报。当学校里有值得信任的成年人，当学生确信学校里的成年人真心为他们的最佳利益着想、而不是简单地采取零容忍态度、当校园风气认为纪律是公正的且他们受到尊重时，学生会更愿意进行举报。我们实际上做过许多研究，探讨是什么让学生愿意报告威胁。答案是积极的学校氛围，也就是我们所说的权威型学校氛围（不是专制型，而是权威型）。也就是说，他们感到规则虽然严格但很公平，学校里的成年人支持他们、尊重他们并且真心为他们着想。我们希望在学校里看到这种氛围。
want to encourage student reporting. And students are going to be more willing to report when there are trusted adults in the school, when they have confidence that the adults in their school have their best interest at heart that aren't going to simply take a zero tolerance approach, that the school climate is that discipline is fair and that they're treated with respect. We've actually done a number of studies of what makes students willing to report a threat. and a positive school climate, what we call an authoritative school climate, not authoritarian, but authoritative. That is, they feel that the rules are strict but fair and that the adults at school support them and respect them and have their best interest at heart. That kind of climate is what we want to see in our schools.
只有这样，学生才会愿意报告威胁。家长也同样愿意报告威胁。我曾参与过一些案例，其中（家长的举报）真的是至关重要的信息。你对主动枪手演练（active shooter drills）有什么看法？我的意思是，现在许多学校都强制要求开展这类演练，并试图教导学生如何在建筑物内应对主动枪手。此前你已经谈到过校园枪击案是多么罕见。我们真的应该这么做吗？我的意思是，这给许多孩子造成了很大的心理创伤。是的。
And then students are willing to report threats. Parents are willing to report threats as well. And I've worked on a number of cases where that was really critical information. What is your view of active shooter drills? I mean, many schools are requiring them now and they're trying to teach students how to respond to an active shooter in the building. Now, you've talked about how unusual shootings are in schools. Should we be doing this? I mean, this traumatizes a lot of kids. Yeah.
我对主动枪手演练非常担忧，尤其是那些涉及某种情景重现、某种模拟、涉及展示武器或模拟人员被枪击或袭击的演练。我认为这些是有害而无益的。我认为对员工进行一些关于如何应对入侵者的培训和指导是有必要的。而且在大多数情况下，入侵者根本不会是主动枪手。学校必须应对的是其他类型的事件，比如有人非法进入大楼。所以，
Well, I am very concerned about active shooter drills, particularly the ones that involve some kind of reenactment, some kind of simulation, ones that involve weapons being displayed or people being simulated, being shot, or attacked. I think those are harmful and not helpful. I think some training and orientation of staff about how to deal with an intruder. And most of the time, the intruder is not going to be an active shooter. There are other kinds of incidents that schools have to deal with, someone coming into the building that shouldn't be there. So there are a reason. to practice security in the school, but I think the reenactments and the simulations have gone too far. I think if law enforcement wants to practice their SWAT procedures, that should be done
在学校里练习安保是有理由的，但我认为情景重现和模拟已经过头了。如果执法部门想要练习他们的特警（SWAT）程序，那应该在没有学生在场的周末进行。我认为试图进行实景演练实在是太过分了。许多安保措施也是如此。你知道，全国各地的学校在数码高科技安保措施上花费了数以十亿计的资金——紧急呼叫按钮、面部识别、枪声探测器、金属探测器、防弹玻璃等等。这些东西极其昂贵。
on a weekend when there aren't students present. I think trying to practice something live is going too far. And the same is true for a lot of the security measures. You know, schools are spending literally billions of dollars nationwide on high-tech security measures, panic buttons, facial recognition, gunshot detectors, metal detectors, bullet-resistant glass, and so forth. And these are extraordinarily expensive. And at the same time, these same schools don't have enough school counselors. They have one school psychologist covering five schools.
与此同时，这些学校却没有足够的学校辅导员。他们可能只有一名学校心理学家要负责五所学校。他们人手严重不足。因此，他们实施预防项目、与学生建立联系的能力——也就是通过这些联系获取能够阻止和遏制枪击的信息——存在着巨大的差距。所以我们需要在安保和预防之间取得更好的平衡。不幸的是，过分强调这些备受关注的、非常戏剧化、令人烦扰和痛苦的枪击事件，会导致人们做出情绪化的决定，让学校董事会做出情绪化的决定。他们会说：“好吧，让我们严加防范，把我们的学校大楼变成一座堡垒。”但我认为，这样做的投资回报率其实并不高。
They're understaffed. And so their ability to implement prevention programs and to build relationships with students where we can get information that can prevent and head off a shooting, that's a huge gap. So we need a better balance between security and prevention. And unfortunately, the emphasis on these high-profile shootings that are very dramatic and troubling and distressing, that leads people to make an emotional decision and school boards to make an emotional decision, it says, all right, let's batten down the hatches, let's make our school building, you know, into a fortress. But I think the return on investment for that is not very good.
如果你从经济学角度以及心理学角度来看，它在建立学生对我们的信任、以及拥有足够的工作人员来与学生一起工作方面，并不是一个很高的回报。让我指出另一个人们有时会忽略的事实。他们把注意力集中在大楼内发生枪击的想法上。所以他们试图封锁大楼。他们试图把所有人挡在大楼外面。他们试图锁上大楼里所有的门。但你知道，如果我们回顾已经发生的校园枪击案，只有30%的校园枪击案是发生在大楼内部的。其余的发生在停车场。发生在足球比赛中。发生在学校外部的场所，这与普遍的枪支暴力情况是一致的。
If you want to take an economic perspective, and from a psychological perspective, it's not a very good return in terms of building trust in our students and having enough staff to work with our students. Let me mention one other fact that people sometimes overlook. They're focused on the idea of a shooting in the building. So they try to lock down the building. They try to keep everybody out of the building. They try to lock all the doors in the building. But you know, if we look at school shootings that have occurred, only 30% of school shootings occurred in the building. So it's the parking lot. It's the football game. It's places outside of the school, which is consistent with gun violence in general. gun violence is more common in these other environments than in the building.
枪支暴力在这些其他环境中比在大楼内部更为普遍。因此，如果我们关心的是安保，单纯让大楼变得安全并不是资金的良好支出，因为枪击更有可能发生在大楼外部。事实上，如果你担心某个年轻人可能具有潜在暴力倾向，他们更有可能在校外对某人开枪。所以如果我们有一位辅导员、一位心理学家、一位社工，正在与我们所担忧的年轻人一起工作，我更宁愿把重点放在防止他们在社区任何地方犯下枪击案上，而不是仅仅局限于“我们能阻止他们在某个特定建筑物的走廊里行凶”这种想法。
So if we're concerned about security, just making the building secure is not a good expenditure of funds because the shooting is more likely to occur outside of the building. And actually, if you have a young person that you're concerned might be potentially violent, they're much more likely to shoot somebody outside of school. So if we've got a counselor, if we've got a psychologist, if we have a social worker, working with a young person that we're concerned about, I would rather be focusing on preventing them from committing a shooting anywhere in the community rather than just the idea that we can prevent them from doing it in the hallway of one particular building.
因此，我认为我们需要对预防有更广泛的思考，而不是狭隘地把学校大楼变成一座堡垒。我想你所说的很多内容会给我们的听众带来希望，其中有许多人都是家长，让他们觉得他们不必像现在这样过于担忧送孩子去上学。所以，让我告诉大家一件我喜欢对家长说的事。当家长们满脑子都是校园枪击案、想象着那是多么可怕的时候，
So I think we've got to think more broadly about prevention here and less narrowly about turning the school building into a fortress. I think a lot of what you're saying will give hope to our listeners, and there's, you know, many of whom are parents, that they don't have to worry as much as perhaps they are about sending their kids to school. So let me tell you one thing that I like to tell parents. And it's kind of a hard message to get to them when they're, when they've thought about school shootings and they imagined how horrible it is.
要让他们听进去这个信息其实挺不容易的。而且，你知道，我曾在公立学校有三个孩子，我还有孙辈。所以，我当然能够从一个家长的角度来看待这个问题。但是，我从科学上知道，如果一个家长因为担心孩子被枪击而害怕送孩子去上学，那么按逻辑推算，这个家长就永远不应该让他们的孩子去餐馆，永远不应该让孩子去便利店，永远不应该让孩子去停车场或公园，因为这些地方的枪击案发生率是学校建筑物的两倍、三倍、四倍。具有讽刺意味的是，学校反而是安全的避风港。
And, you know, I had three children in the public schools. I've got grandchildren. So I'm, I'm certainly able to look at this from a parent's perspective. But, but I know scientifically that if a parent is afraid to send. their child to school because they think of the risk the child could be shot, then that parent logically should never let their child go to a restaurant, never let their child go into a convenience store, never let their child go into a parking lot or a park, because those areas have double, triple, quadruple the shootings that school buildings have. Schools, ironically, are safe havens.
你知道，我的三个孩子都在公立学校上学，我也有孙辈了。所以，我当然能够从家长的角度来看待这个问题。但是，从科学上讲我深知，如果一个家长因为担心孩子被枪击的风险而不敢送孩子去学校，那么这位家长从逻辑上来说，就绝不应该让孩子去餐馆，绝不应该让孩子去便利店，绝不应该让孩子去停车场或公园，因为这些地方发生的枪击事件是学校建筑的两倍、三倍、四倍。具有讽刺意味的是，学校反而是避风港。
in many, many communities with high crime. Schools are the safest places for our kids to be. And I know it's hard because as a parent, you know, we can imagine those school shootings and they're so horrendous and we've got to do everything we can to prevent them. But we've got to prevent the shootings that occur all over our society. We have about 300 shootings every day in the United States. We have over 100 people killed by gunfire every day in the United States. We just don't hear about those cases. We hear about the ones in the school building that are so heartrending, so heartbreaking.
在许多许多犯罪率高的社区里，学校其实是我们孩子最安全的地方。我知道这很难，因为作为父母，我们可以想象那些校园枪击案，它们是如此骇人听闻，我们必须尽一切努力去阻止它们。但我们也必须阻止在我们社会各处发生的枪击事件。在美国，我们每天大约发生300起枪击事件。在美国，我们每天有100多人死于枪击。只是我们没有听到那些案件。我们听到的是学校建筑里那些令人心碎、极其悲痛的事件。
But less than 2% of homicides of school-age people occur in schools. Less than 2% of the homicides occur in school. 98% occur outside of school. So I want measures that focus on protecting all of our kids and not just in the confines of the school building. So just to wrap up, what's next for you in your research? What are the questions you're still trying to answer? Well, gosh, there's lots of questions because we want to make this training program effective. We want to make the implementation effective. We want to make sure it's fair and equitable. So we've done a number of studies on that. We currently have a national
但学龄人群的凶杀案中，在学校发生的不到2%。在学校发生的凶杀案不到2%。98%发生在学校外面。所以我希望采取关注保护所有孩子的措施，而不仅仅局限于学校建筑内。那么总结一下，您的研究下一步是什么？您还在尝试解答哪些问题？哦，天哪，有很多问题，因为我们希望使这个培训计划有效。我们希望使其实施有效。我们要确保它是公平公正的。所以我们已经在这方面做了一些研究。我们目前正在开展一项全国性的
study with districts from six states implementing the C-Stag model. We're measuring the fidelity of implementation, that is how high quality are they following the procedure? Because schools have limited resources and staff are often burdened with lots of responsibility. So what can we do to make sure that they follow the threat assessment protocol fully? And if they do, do they get better results? We want to show that. We also want to show the equity and fairness of threat assessment. I know in school discipline, black students are removed from school at disproportionate rates, about double the rates of white students for school discipline in general. What we found with threat assessment is that disparity shrinks almost to zero.
研究，有来自六个州的学区正在实施C-Stag模型。我们正在衡量实施的保真度，也就是他们遵循程序的质量有多高？因为学校资源有限，教职员工往往肩负着很多责任。所以我们能做些什么来确保他们完全遵循威胁评估方案呢？如果他们做到了，能取得更好的结果吗？我们想证明这一点。我们还想展示威胁评估的公平性和公正性。我知道在学校纪律处分中，黑人学生被学校开除或停学的比例不成比例，大约是白人学生因一般学校纪律处分受罚比例的两倍。我们在威胁评估中发现，这种差距几乎缩小到零。
Our differences in our latest study between white and black students were about 2%. Not 200%, 2%. So we're getting very equitable outcomes across racial groups, also across groups defined by disability. We know that in the United States, students with disabilities. disabilities get removed from school at one and a half to double the rate of other students without disabilities, but not with a threat assessment. If we can route those students into a threat assessment, their outcomes are no different, no different than the students without disabilities. Same for families with low income. We know that low income families often get
在我们最新的研究中，白人学生和黑人学生之间的差异约为2%。不是200%，而是2%。因此，我们在各个种族群体之间，以及在按残疾定义的各个群体之间，都获得了非常公平的结果。我们知道在美国，残疾学生被学校开除或停学的比率是没有残疾的其他学生的1.5到2倍，但在威胁评估中情况并非如此。如果我们能将这些学生纳入威胁评估，他们的结果将没有区别，与没有残疾的学生没有任何区别。低收入家庭也是如此。我们知道低收入家庭往往会得到
fewer services and more punishment, but in large-scale studies of threat assessment, we find they're treated comparably. So we're very optimistic that we can get some very positive benefits from students, quite apart from the horror of the school shooting. We can discipline students in a more equitable manner. And in most cases, 75% of the cases they're receiving services rather than being put out of school. Well, Dr. Cornell, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting.
更少的服务和更多的惩罚，但在对威胁评估的大规模研究中，我们发现他们得到了平等的对待。因此，我们非常乐观地认为，除了校园枪击案的恐怖之外，我们还能为学生带来一些非常积极的好处。我们可以以更公正的方式对学生进行纪律处分。在大多数情况下，即75%的案例中，他们得到的是服务，而不是被赶出学校。好吧，科内尔博士，我要感谢您今天能来参加我们的节目。这非常有趣。
Thank you very much for the opportunity. I'm happy to follow up if anyone has questions. wants to contact me. We've got lots of research and materials to share. Oh, great. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits subscription to our award-winning magazine, Monitor on Psychology, as well as discounts on our books
非常感谢您提供这个机会。如果有人有问题或想联系我，我随时乐意跟进。我们有大量研究和材料可以分享。太好了，谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留下评价。对于那些想要更多了解心理学和美国心理协会（APA）工作的人，您可以作为支持者加入我们。您不必非得是一名心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology），以及购买我们的书籍
and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science and discipline, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.a.org slash speaking. That's aty as and tom.a.a.org slash speaking. If you have comments, questions or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology. at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wineran. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association,
和其他出版物的折扣。因此，如果心理学是您的热情所在，或者您只是想更多地了解这门科学和学科，您可以通过访问at.a.a.org slash speaking成为支持者。也就是aty as and tom.a.a.org slash speaking。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见、问题或想法，请发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology. at APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·温纳兰（Lee Wineran）制作。谢谢您的收听。代表美国心理协会，
I'm Kim Mills. Security program on spreadsheets, new regulations piling up, and audit tread? It's time for Vanta. Vanta automates security and compliance, brings evidence into one place, and cuts audit prep by 82%.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。电子表格上的安全项目、不断堆积的新规以及审计准备？是时候使用 Vanta 了。Vanta 可以自动化安全和合规流程，将证据汇集到一个地方，并将审计准备时间缩短 82%。
Less manual work, clear visibility, faster deals, zero chaos. Call it compliance, or call it Calm clients. Get it? Join the 15,000 companies using Vanta to prove trust. Go to VANTA.com slash calm. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更少的手动工作、清晰的可见性、更快的交易、零混乱。称之为合规，或者称之为平静的客户（Calm clients）。听懂了吗？加入使用 Vanta 证明信任的 15,000 家公司吧。请访问 VANTA.com slash calm。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。